good afternoon good afternoon my name is
Josh real asking and I'm a senior
financial management major from Temecula
California it is my honor to introduce
our next speaker
Larry elder is a radio and television
host author and attorney he earned his
BA at Brown University and his JD at the
University of Michigan his daily radio
program the larry elder show was first
broadcast in 1994 making it the
longest-running afternoon Drivetime show
in Los Angeles mr. elder is the director
and producer of Michael and me a
documentary film that examines the
history and use of guns in America he is
a former host of the television shows
moral court in the larry elder show
first work on television he received an
aegis award of excellence a Tele award
and an emerald city Gold Award of
Excellence he's the author of numerous
books including what's race got to do
with it why it's time to stop the
stupidest argument in America now please
join me in welcoming mr. Larry elder
Wow thank you thank you so much I really
appreciate it
before I get started any active or
retired military please stand bless you
god bless you let me give you the Cliff
Notes version of how I got into talk
radio and into media but for Dennis
Prager I wouldn't be here I was on
Dennis Prager show and the general
manager heard me like me gave me a 2-day
audition after one day he said if you
want this job you have it go out tonight
have a good time don't speak so quickly
but before that I was living and working
in Cleveland this is about two years
earlier when I got the bug to do radio I
was writing op-ed pieces in every now
and then when we get published I had no
public publisher I wasn't syndicated at
the time I just wrote pieces and would
send them blindly to newspapers the two
newspapers in the Northeast Ohio area
where the Cleveland Plain Dealer in the
Akron Beacon Journal and every now and
then one would be published and I wrote
one that was published in The Plain
Dealer where I talked about how racism
was no longer a major problem in America
this is almost 25 years ago
revolutionary thing to say now let alone
then I got a phone call from a producer
of a radio show he said would you mind
coming on tonight and talking about your
article do you truly believe that racism
is no longer a major problem in America
and I said yes I don't say racism is
gone he'll never be gone as long as
there are idiots and morons we're always
gonna have some problems but but do I
believe that racism is strong enough in
the current year to stop anybody willing
to work hard stay focused he'll know he
said great come on the show Cleveland is
about 60% black so almost all the phone
calls I got were from black people and I
was called an Uncle Tom a bootlicking
Uncle Tom a bug-eyed foot shuffling
bootlicking Uncle Tom
in Oreo brown on the outside white on
the inside coconut same concept the
Antichrist and then I was called the
name that you call a black man when you
really really really want to hurt him I
was called Republican a man can only
take so much so I was determined never
to do that again I'm driving back to
work this is the most wasteful hour of
my entire life I get into my office
phone rings it's the general manager of
the station where I just was he said you
were amazing I was oh my goodness you
were on for an entire hour
you took difficult positions you
defended them without losing your sense
of humor have you ever thought about
doing talk radio I said no he said I
have a guy going on vacation I'd love
for you to fit it sit it sit in for him
for that week I said no he said why I
said I don't like it he said why don't
you like it I said I don't like being
yelled at and I don't like having others
yell at me he said are you married at
the time I was he said do me a favor go
home and talk this over with your wife I
think you may have a different attitude
tomorrow I said I'm happy to do that but
I won't change my mind went home that
night I mentioned it to my then wife
Cindy and she said what do you think
about talk radio I said know very little
about it other than it seems shallow
glib and stupid she said it is you'd be
good at it
gives you some idea what happened to
that marriage I I am fascinated by this
idea that President Obama said that
racism was in America's DNA credible
statement you look at the polls in 1950
in the 50s when white Americans were
asked would you ever vote for a black
person for president those who said yes
were in the single digits how can racism
be in our DNA if 50 years later 60 years
later a black man gets elected president
United States of America it's not
possible if racism isn't our DNA Obama
in my opinion in eight years did a great
deal of damage to race relations came in
with a great deal of hope do you
remember the polls after he got elected
he was at 70% that's more than the
people who voted for him which shows
people were pulling for him and they
were pulling for him because they
thought he could bring the nation
together at least as far as race
relations are concerned the first time I
saw Obama was in 2004 I was in Boston in
the arena when he did the warm-up speech
for John Kerry he lit the place up I
turned to my producer and I said this
guy's gonna run for president someday
he's gonna get elected he didn't say
anything left it's not there's no
there's no blue country there's no red
country this United States of America
anybody could've given that speech but
he came in well I saw his first
interview on 60 minutes he interviewed
Steve Croft this is before he became
president when he was running at this
point he had now begun to get momentum
and take it away from Hillary and Steve
Croft said to him senator if you don't
get the nomination will it be because of
racism and I said let's see how this guy
answers and he said no if I don't get
the nomination it will be because I have
failed to articulate a vision that the
American people can accept I said
hallelujah I'm not gonna vote for a left
wing tax bin regulated person but at
least he's not a victim
at least he's not whining and bitching
and moaning about how the white man is
holding holding him back I was stunned
he gets in and he undid everything he
did in that interview with Steve Croft
in my opinion the first time he had a
chance to say something conciliatory to
heal this nation was when the
Cambridge Police broken up went to the
house of his friend Henry Louis Gates
you might remember the incident Gates
was coming back from vacation forgot his
door key so he and the cab driver broke
into his own house some lady in the
neighborhood saw it called 9-1-1 don't
you want that I won't like neighbours to
do that police show up go to this house
very politely ask him to come out of the
house have no idea who he is whether or
not he broke into the house and rather
than come out and politely show his ID
skip gates this tenured Harvard
professor said I'll come out if your
mama tells me or something like that I
mean really really what did Obama say
and I quote the Cambridge police acted
stupidly close quote he got hammered so
much that's why he did that stupid beer
summit Trayvon Martin if I had a son
Obama said he would have looked like
Trayvon what does that even mean what's
the point in injecting yourself in this
anyway
fast forward jury criminal trial found
him not guilty there was one black
alternate who didn't participate but
when asked he would have said he said I
would have reached the same conclusion
race never came up during the jury
deliberations Ferguson Obama's giving a
speaker for the United Nations and he
says well we have our own problems here
too there's a town called Ferguson he
went on and did a riff about how
Ferguson is a microcosm of the problems
America has in race and you know what
happened grand jury found the officer
completely not guilty the Justice
Department examined it and determined
that while this man did not do anything
wrong the Ferguson Police Department is
institutionally racist why while the
city is 67% black but 85 percent of the
traffic stops are of black people 18
point gap ergo racism really New York
has 25% black people 55 percent of the
traffic stops of people are black a 30
point difference yet the New York Police
Department at least the street cops are
probably people of color while the
Ferguson PD is almost all white how can
one that's predominantly people of color
have a bigger gap in traffic stops than
the one that's all white unless they're
both race system the answer is you can't
do it by that
you have to look at rates of offending
and about two years before this happened
there was a Department of Justice study
by the National Institutes of justice
which is their research arm call traffic
stops and race and it turned out every
offense you name it whether it's
speeding driving without a license
driving without a seatbelt driving with
an out of proper peg attacks whatever
the offense is a black person was more
likely to commit it so the National
Institutes of justice the research arm
the DOJ wrote a paper about it and said
the differences in traffic stops have to
do with differences in offending in
other words they found no racism some
years ago at the New Jersey Turnpike a
lot of blacks were complaining that they
were being pulled over because of racial
profiling the then Governor Christie
Todd Whitman ordered a study study came
back and the researchers found out that
by and large they couldn't find anything
wrong often these stops took place at
night where the cars are going so fast
and it's dark you couldn't tell who's in
it anyway what race they were anyway and
they found nothing she didn't like the
conclusions
she hired another group to do a
different study using different
methodology they reached the same
conclusion sorry
no one says racism doesn't exist but for
crying out loud
this twisting over backwards to try and
prove things that don't exist when there
are real things it's interesting when
people talk about things like
institutional racism they never
mentioned things like the minimum wage
the first minimum way through the 1938
it was 25 cents a paper by the Cato
Institute the libertarian think-tank out
of Washington DC concludes that because
of the minimum wage and other measures
done by FDR during the New Deal blacks
over a period of years lost probably
about 500,000 jobs at one time a black
teen was the most likely to be employed
as between a white teen white male black
male think about it they had less skills
and they were able to offer their offer
their talents whatever they were for
less money along comes the government
and requires employers to pay a minimum
wage therefore shutting out people
willing to work for less money and these
are people usually with fewer skills
there's a law that was also started
during the Depression called the
davis-bacon Act davis-bacon were two
Republicans and they wanted to make sure
that union members were not out competed
by blacks willing to work for less money
so they passed a law called the
davis-bacon Act which requires anybody
bidding on a government contract to pay
quote prevailing union wages close what
in other words wages white people will
accept it was specifically designed to
foreclose competition from blacks the
only reason I think the Democrats never
mentioned this because there are two
Republicans I did it is because the pro
union part outweighs the racism part so
as a result Democrats almost never bring
it up fascinating getting back to Obama
I read his book his first book and in
his first book he describes his meeting
of Reverend Jeremiah Wright oh he says
Wright was late to the church so he got
there and began having a discussion with
Wright's longtime secretary a single mom
with a son in high school and she told
Obama that her son wants to be in the
marching band and his school does not
have a marching band however there's a
suburban school that has a marching band
predominately white suburban school that
not only has a marching band but also
has free uniforms so she was thinking of
moving to that area so her son could
have a better education and Jeremiah
Wright was trying to talk her out of it
and Obama said why and she said Jeremiah
Wright believes that the son my son
won't know who he is
won't know who he is as a black person
if he lives in predominantly white
neighborhood end of quote
no think about think about the person to
whom she's telling this this is a half
white man whose white mother sent him
back to Hawaii so that he could be
raised by his white grandparents because
she wanted to make sure he got a better
education he ended up going to Punahou
the state's most prestigious private
institution boarding school and then he
went to Occidental College in LA for the
first two years a very selective
expensive private school finished up at
Columbia and then of course graduated to
Harvard the man never set foot in the
private school in a public school and
yet
when Obama and his wife were considering
going to Washington DC if we got elected
she made a big display out of talking
about all the public schools that they
visited and I went on the air and I said
I'll be a cross-dressing cosmonaut if
Obama chooses a public school he didn't
he went to his girls to Sidwell Friends
the same school that Chelsea went to
very very expensive yet this is a man
who runs a party who opposed us that
opposes vouchers the ability to take the
money and use the money to give your
child a better education do you know in
Baltimore there are five public high
schools where not a single child can do
math and read at state proficiency
levels which aren't that high in the
first place not a single one there's a
middle school where not a single child
can do math and can read at state levels
of proficiency yet again this is the
party that adamantly opposes vouchers
why ninety-five percent of black people
go in and pull the lever for a party
that says I don't care whether or not
your kid's gonna go to an under
Parliament underperforming public school
and I don't care that you don't care
he's going how somebody can pull a lever
for that party is beyond me if there is
a route to the middle class what is it
other than education what is it and
you're telling me that I've got to send
my kid to a school I went to school
called Crenshaw High School anybody see
the movie boys in the hood okay that's
that's the school that I went to and
it's about an the movie was about an
urban high school and a bunch of kids
and the school right now is said to be a
[ __ ] school there are two major black
gangs in LA the Bloods and the Crips and
schools are will adopt a gang or gainful
adoptive school the Crips have adopted
my school the reason I know that is
because ice-t the rapper went there
about ten years later and totally I read
an article in the LA Times a few years
ago three years ago I believe it was
front-page article 3% of the kids at my
former high school can do math and can
do reading at grade level and that's up
from two
percent the year before and we want to
talk about institutional racism blows my
mind blows my mind I understand the feud
that Donald Trump is having right now
with Jay Z you hear about that Jay Z
says something very critical about Obama
about Trump and Trump tweeted well black
unemployment is at an all-time low
and jay-z says something to the effect
of well money isn't everything it's
about how people are treated an easy
thing to say when you have a net worth
of eight hundred million dollars isn't
it isn't it similar to what Nancy Pelosi
and Debbie wasserman-schultz have said
about the tax cuts chump change
crumbs doesn't amount to very much Nancy
Pelosi has a net worth of over two
hundred million dollars I suppose it is
crumbs to her but to regular normal
people its food on the table I had Tavis
Smiley on my show once and he had Cornel
West with him who used to call himself a
Marxist he has another fancy name now
but they're both in the studio so it was
a fair fight and I said I said Tavis
during the Reagan years black adult
unemployment fell faster than did white
adult unemployment Hispanic unemployment
fell faster than did white unemployment
black teenage unemployment fell faster
then did white teenage unemployment all
because Ronald Reagan cut the top
marginal tax rate from seventy percent
to twenty eight percent you put money in
the pockets of producers and they
produce Tavis said that's not true those
numbers are wrong I'll have the correct
numbers for you on Monday that was six
years ago I know I know our postal
service can be sluggish but come on the
refusal to give Ronald Reagan any credit
is just stunning this President Obama
did the opposite of what Ronald Reagan
did Reagan cut taxes dramatically Obama
raised them Reagan continued the
deregulation programs that had
begone under Jimmy Carter one of the few
things Jimmy Carter did that I approve
and he slowed down the rate of he slowed
down the size of government trump has by
not producing some of these vacancies
that we'd ever need in the first place
this is the first president that's
really truly cut down the size of
government staff in my lifetime and I'm
I'm unbelievably impressed by that I
have often been asked why it is that I
am so optimistic why is it I'm so
positive and it from my parents I had
great parents my mother and my father I
remember my mother was from Huntsville
Alabama and she told me that in the
South there was a chimney maker he was
black couldn't either read nor write but
he was the most employed person in the
south black or white because he could
build chimneys and didn't smoke and she
said it wasn't because the white people
in the country invited him in for dinner
they needed his skills Booker T
Washington said whenever a Negro boy
learns to cook too so the practice
medicine as well as or better than
anybody else he or she will be rewarded
because the world wants the best my
mother told me that when she grew up
there were two theaters a country
theater and the downtown theater the
downtown theatre had first-run movies
the country theatre had second-run
movies they were both owned by by white
man two different white men in the
downtown theater you could go if you
were black but you had to sit on the
balcony you couldn't sit downstairs and
the country theater you could sit
anywhere you wanted suddenly and the
country theater only had second run
movies the downtown theater had
first-run movies so kids went to the
downtown theater in order to see movies
that they would not be able to see for
six months or a year in the country
theater all of a sudden the theater
owner in the country began getting
first-run movies guess what happened to
the downtown theater and their anti
sitting at the floor policy they changed
it like that there was no law there's no
ticket there was no March
the guy started losing money and all of
a sudden it was no lower unacceptable
it's no longer acceptable for blacks to
sit in the signal balcony the point I'm
making of course is that invest in
yourself make yourself a value to the
community and the way you do that is
through hard work
self investment self-improvement and
education there's no other route if
there is I found it my father and I did
not get along I couldn't stand the SOB I
thought he was mean I thought he was
gruff I thought it was Honore and the
thing about him that bothered me the
most is whatever he was mean or gruff or
honoré about wasn't necessarily the same
thing the second time see unpredictable
he seemed like he would come home and
just be smoldering we never even liked
him in the house my father was a janitor
and then he saved his nickels and dimes
and started a cafe oh great now we all
have to work with him so I'm working
with my dad and from time I was 10 years
old to time I was 15 years old I hated
every day of it my dad worked me harder
than anybody else held me to a higher
standard than anybody else and every now
and then when things really get tense
during rush hour 11:30 to 1 o'clock my
dad but recurse at me if I did something
he thought was wrong now I was afraid of
my father I'd like to tell you that I
told myself the next time he curses at
me I'm gonna walk up to him and I must
say see here pal let's have it out right
now but I'm afraid of him so I told my
father told myself the next time he
yells at me I'm out of here I was gonna
leave you just don't do that the
waitress called in sick that day now I'm
talking about a little little cafe 1618
seats which was called in that day she
was sick so my dad and I were just
working together and my dad cursed at me
I went in the back I took the robe off
and I left my dad came home that night
Keith's restaurant was full of people by
the way he was for you rias why did you
leave and I said I got tired of the way
you spoke to me my dad paid me $10 a day
plus tips he took the $10 out of his
pocket balled it up and threw it at me
he walked out of my bedroom my dad at
night and I speak for 10 years and when
I say didn't speak I mean nothing he
came home late so was easy to avoid him
when I graduate from college from high
school I went away to college in the
East Coast so we didn't say
each other and then when I would come
home over the years I would make sure we
didn't talk so for ten years my dad and
I said nothing to each other and by
nothing I mean not even do you think
it's gonna rain how those rams gonna do
nothing now I'm 25 years old I've gone
to college I've gone to law school now
I'm working for a prominent firm in
Cleveland and I can't sleep I'm not
quite sure why but I think it has
something to do with unresolved issues
with my dad I don't know
so I called my secretary and I said
cancel all my appointments I'm going to
LA I didn't tell my parents I was coming
because I do with my dad to prepare for
this confrontation I figured it'd last
five minutes I would call him a mean
ornery dad he called me an ungrateful
son at least we'd clear the air so I got
there I had two big bags I said dad I
want to talk to you he was stopped he
said sure so I put your bags in the back
I said no dad I'm only gonna be here for
about five minutes he said well you know
what time we close in an hour and I'll
come out we'll talk then so I sat there
for an hour and I'm watching the cafe
and I said all right Larry stay calm
don't tee off on the SOB just articulate
a few high points and then he'll call
you an ungrateful son at least you guys
would have discussed it maybe you'll be
able to sleep better
so dad sat down and of course I teed off
on him I spoke for 20 minutes non-stop I
guess you guys can see how I can go
every whipping every spanking every
slight every indignity anything he ever
said to me I talked to him about it I
just hit him with it and my dad just
took it every now and then he pour more
coffee but he just took it and then I
ran out of ammo and my dad looked up he
goes is that it you didn't speak to me
for 10 years because of that and I said
yes and he said let me tell you about my
father now keep in mind I knew my dad
was an only child and I admit his mother
once outside of that I knew nothing
about him and didn't care I knew he had
no relatives because nobody ever came
over nobody ever called for him we never
got any Christmas present from anybody
so I knew that he was an only child as
all I knew and I didn't
care much beyond that my dad said I'm 25
years old now you know your name elder I
said yes he said that is not my
biological father
what elder is a man who was in my mom's
life he said probably the longest he was
an alcoholic who was physically abusive
to her physically abusive to me he may
work sometime when he did work he'd come
home bring the check give it to her tell
her to keep it by Wednesday he'd want
the money she wouldn't give it to him he
beat the crap out of her if I intervened
he'd beat the crap out of me she had a
series of boyfriend's like that my dad
said one worse than the other the first
only time I first time I saw my dad cry
was talking about this man and my dad
said he came home at the age of 13 and
he was quarreling with his mom's then
boyfriend a different man the mom sided
with the boyfriend through my father out
of the house never to return you're
talking about a black boy Jim Crow South
right at the beginning of the Great
Depression he never went back home walk
down the road took whatever job he could
Pullman Porter shoeshine boy
you name it ultimately he got a job as a
Pullman Porter which was a big deal they
were the largest private employer of
blacks in those days so my dad was able
to travel all around the country he came
to California and it was sunny and
people seemed a little more friendly my
dad thought maybe someday I relocate to
California world war two Pearl Harbor my
dad joins the Marines my dad was a
Montford Point Marines they were the
first black Marines or 20,000 of them
Congress a few years ago they gave them
a Congressional Gold Medal my dad got
his posthumously I said dad why the
Marines he said they go where the action
is and I love the uniforms
they made him a cook in charge of
cooking facilities he became a staff
sergeant on the island of Guam the bomb
fell my dad went back to Chattanooga
where he had met married my mom and now
with all this experience as a cook my
dad wanted to get him a job as a cook he
goes to restaurant to restaurant to
restaurant in Chattanooga and he's told
we don't hire [ __ ] my dad went to an
unemployment office lady says you went
to the wrong door my dad goes out she's
covered only goes to that door - the
very same woman who sent him out my dad
went with my mother and said this is BS
I'm going to California and he goes out
to California he said I'm gonna spin a
couple of days i'ma find a job and I'll
send for you so my dad walked around for
about day and a half restaurant to
restaurant to restaurant in California
in 1946 and he's told you don't have any
references which is California's way of
saying the same thing they were just
more polite my dad said I'll work for
free just give me a reference after two
weeks they wouldn't even do that
my dad closed an unemployment office
this time just one door they have
nothing my dad said I'll take the first
thing you have she sat there for a day
and a half lady calls him up I have a
job don't know if you want it my dad
said I'm sure I want it what is it
she says a job at Nabisco brand Brad's
cleaning toilets my dad took that job
for 10 years took a second job at
Barbara and bred for ten years also
cleaning toilets cook for a family on
the weekends and went to night school
two to three nights a week to get his
GED the man never slept which is why he
was tired why he was grouchy why he was
crotchety and as my dad spoke he got
bigger and bigger and bigger and I got
smaller and smaller and smaller and I
said dad I am so sorry please accept my
apology I didn't know he said you're a
child of course you didn't know but just
follow the advice I've always given you
and your brother's hard work wins you
get out of life what you put into it you
cannot control the outcome but you are
100% in control of the effort and before
you moan and whine about what somebody
did do you go to the nearest mirror look
at it and say how could I have changed
the outcome and no matter what you do no
matter how thoroughly you follow my
instructions sooner or later it bad
things will happen how you respond to
those bad things will tell your mother
in me whether or not we raised a man not
too much pressure dad how much time we
have I want to give you a couple more
stories okay my my mother and father
were married 56 years my mom was a
lifelong Democrat my dad was a lifelong
Republican you should have heard the
arguments they had across the table that
was fascinating during during Watergate
my dad thought it was so inconsequential
so some people broke into the Watergate
and Richard Nixon covered it up and
therefore he should leave office and
what they said yes my dad said no my dad
even recommended that Nixon make new
tapes with Haldeman and Ehrlichman and
replaced the old tapes he thought it was
that silly
fast-forward look at the polls most
Americans now believe he never should
have resigned most Americans believe it
was inconsequential especially when you
look at what's happened the last eight
years my goodness
Hillary has a server in her basement
sent and received classified information
denied that she did but she did burn
33,000 emails when they were under
subpoena my goodness the tax exempt
person at the IRS is rejecting
conservative applications
she takes the fifth a bunch of times
right now she's in a nice home in the
suburb suburbs of Washington DC
collecting her pension and Richard Nixon
resigned because some people he had
nothing to do with broke into the in the
end of the Watergate my dad's instincts
turned out to have been right my mother
began voting Republican she voted twice
for Reagan she voted twice for Bush I
said mother why have you not changed
your registration and she gave me some
answer and it turned out the bottom line
was it was a motion the Democrats have
been so successful in brand-new
Republicans as bad means buried in races
even my mother despite the fact of
pulling the lever for the Republican
Party all those years still couldn't
bring herself
to really register it's amazing the
reputation that the Democrats have I was
in New York for one of the conventions
had some Press Pass on a white cab
driver and I were talking and I guess he
assumed because I was black I was I was
a Democrat and began ragging about the
Republican Party and I said what's the
difference in your opinion between the
two parties and he stopped and he said
well my father says that the Republican
Party only cares about General Electric
the Democratic Party cares about you and
me I said is it possible to have both
and all of a sudden you stop talking
about politics he realized that it
wasn't wasn't a Democrat I am amazed at
this Trump derangement syndrome Trump is
the most moderate Republican president
in my lifetime he's a guy who came into
office and said same-sex marriage is
settled law he supported the kilo
decision that most Republicans hated of
the decision that allowed a private
person to use a tax-exempt status that
the government has in order to build
something private as opposed to for a
school or a road or something like that
it was a 5-4 decision that most
Republicans hated in Donald Trump a
developer supports it Donald Trump's
daughter says that there should be weeks
of paid Family Medical Leave who's what
Republican says that and this daca deal
that Obama that Trump put out that would
grant a pathway to citizenship for 1.8
million people I can't imagine the
Democrats getting a better deal but they
don't want it the reason they don't want
it in my opinion is because they want
the board board is to remain porous
because they can't win elections
otherwise the Democratic Party has lost
the white vote since 1964 unless the
Democratic Party is successful in
convincing people like you to tax spin
and regulate they need to bring in
people who do want to tax spin and
regulate and these are people from third
world countries and it has gradually
changed a nation the nature of this
country to the point where we have
almost a 50/50 nation and if we bring in
millions of more people from third world
countries who have the kinds of views
I'm talking about who don't have any
understanding of the concept of
federalism any understanding of the
concept of differences between church
and state
notice standing of the concept of
limited government we're gonna have more
and more Democrats and that's what
they're doing they are minting Democrats
I've asked this question I sent a tweet
one time to Wolf Blitzer and I said the
next time you have on luis Gutierrez the
congressman from Chicago the most open
borders guy up there
please ask him if he would oppose the
wall if 80% of illegals turn citizens
would vote Republican
I dare say they'd have a different
attitude do you really believe that
Democrats will be pushing for statehood
of Washington DC if it weren't likely
that two more senators will be Democrat
and at least one more Congress person
would be Democrat does anybody really
believe that people like Terry McAuliffe
would want convicted felons to have the
right to vote if they would not
overwhelmingly likely vote the
Democratic Party so why then is it
cynical of us of me to say I don't want
a bunch more Democrats pulling the lever
to in my opinion vote against my
interest and against the interest of the
country why is that wrong why is that
bad I want to end with a couple of
stories every now and then I'm just
reminded of just how wonderful this
country is I was at a gas station
maybe six eight months ago pull into my
late model car given to me like one of
my sponsors I get out I had a designer
suit on one of my sponsors credit card
substantial limit I'm getting premium
gas next to the bay car pulls up
rumbling a 1968 Dodge Polara with a
busted muffler two guys get out very
very pale pale pasty skin I can tell
they're relatives by the way they look
it was out-of-state plate I don't want
to malign any states I won't tell you
what state it is but collectively they
might have had 810 teeth between the two
of them
they got $5.00 of regular and they
Rumble off and I said wow just think
those two dudes owe me reparations is
this a great country or what
thank you
last one then we'll do Q&A I took the
course in high school called
afro-american literature
read a poem by a man named Countee
Cullen and it went like this while
riding through a Baltimore so small and
full of Glee I saw a young Baltimore en
keepall looking straight at me now I was
young and very small like he was no whit
bigger and so I smiled but he poked out
his tongue and called me a [ __ ] I saw
the whole of Baltimore from May until
September of all the things that
happened there that's all that I
remember well the class was furious
teacher was furious I was furious
the teacher talked about the permanent
stain to his psyche that he'll always
consider himself to be a second-class
citizen that he'll never forget this so
I went home I knew my mother was gonna
have a different take I didn't know what
it was gonna be and I walk in she's in
the kitchen I'll never forget it frying
chicken I said mom we read a poem in
class I want to get your reaction to it
she said sure as it goes like this while
riding through a Baltimore so small and
full of Glee I saw young Baltimorean
people looking straight at me now I was
young and very smaller he was no whit
bigger and so I smiled but he poked out
his tongue and called me [ __ ]
I saw the whole of Baltimore from May
until September of all the things that
happened there that's all that I
remember my mother closed door oven turn
to me and he said she said Larry what a
darn shame he let something so trivial
spoiled his vacation how many wings do
you want thank you so much for having me
may God bless you and may God continue
to bless the United States of America
thank you so much
please raise your hand and a microphone
will be brought to you that your energy
was killing me
we like the Sun over there I mean these
two guys got burned didn't they okay
Thank You Larry for coming to Hillsdale
College to speak my name is Doyle I'm a
sophomore
I like your fragrant video on the
problem with lack of fatherhood in the
black community and so there I heard
this saying from conservatives that
politics is downstream from our culture
but then it's from the rings of
Aristotle what he says is that culture
is actually downstream from politics in
terms of the way we make our laws and so
when solving the problem of the lack of
fathers in black to meet in the black
community how do we saw which
perspective show he is to solve that
problem okay
in 1925 1965 Daniel Patrick Moynihan the
later on I became a Democratic senator
from New York wrote a report called the
Negro family a case for national action
I read the book when I was a freshman in
college in 1970 and I was in a sociology
class I think when I read it and I was
one of maybe two or three blacks in the
class and most of the whites in the
class thought the book was racist was
demeaning and that Moynihan was a
patriarchal person I'm the only one in
the class I thought there was something
there and the kids thought I was bizarre
that was 1965 25 percent of black kids
were born outside of wedlock roughly ten
to fifteen percent of white kids were
born outside of wedlock fast forward now
seventy-three percent of black kids are
born outside of wedlock twenty-five
percent of white kids are the same
number that triggered that alarming book
and forty percent of Hispanic had to
point outside of wedlock
now why is this a problem don't take me
take Obama Obama said a kid raised
without a dad is five times more likely
to be poor nine times more likely to
drop out of school 20 times more likely
to end up in college what else is there
to say
it is far in a way the number one
problem facing the black community
what in my opinion has happened is when
Lyndon Johnson launched the war on
poverty with the best of intentions
fifty years and two trill and 22
trillion dollars later this is the
result what we've done is we've
incentivized women to marry the
government we've allowed men to abandon
their financial and moral
responsibilities the answer is to end
government welfare and welfare should be
done at the private sector level the the
church level nonprofits like United Way
I volunteer for United Way for three
months once we do a lot of work for food
for the poor organizations cut taxes let
people use their own money and donate
their own money and and the money will
be donated in a way that's more
efficient and much more likely to change
behavior even if it's just on a level of
efficiency Tom so the economist says
that for every dollar that taxpayers
spend on welfare about 33 cents gets
down to the attendant beneficiary for
organizations like United Way
ninety-five cents on the dollar gets
down to the intended beneficiary because
so many people are volunteers so the
answer is to unhook people from the
welfare state and don't again don't go
by me go by what they say themselves in
eighteen in nineteen eighty six the LA
Times did a survey of poor and non poor
people and asked do you feel that
welfare is a crutch or is it a stopgap
to get you on your own two feet the
majority of people on on majority of
poor people 64 percent thought it was a
crutch and that it was a [ __ ] that was
1986 they've done the same survey years
later in 2006 and as many poor people
thought it was a crutch I thought it was
a stepping stone to get you on your own
your own two feet so there's a debate
even within the class of people we call
poor as to whether or not government
welfare really works it's a problem most
people in this room probably read
democracy in America by Alexis de
Tocqueville most people probably have
not read another book he wrote around
the same time called memoirs on
paparizou he had money he was able to
travel around the world and he noticed
that the wealthiest country England
seemed to have the most beggars most
street people and it turns out that
England was the first modern state to
have
a welfare no-questions-asked welfare and
as a result you had more and more
beggars coming there and he concluded
that there was a connection between
offering people free money and and
laziness but he didn't know what to do
about it because there are certain
people that need help and you can't look
at somebody and tell which ones need
help which ones don't
so he says it's a dilemma it still is a
dilemma but we but the first part of the
Hippocratic oath is do no harm we are
doing harm by saying here's free money
to you irrespective of your behavior
irrespective of decision that you've
made irrespective of decision that you
make in the future you're still gonna
get this money that is morally wrong
mr. Oliver I'm John sadistically most
people get their political views from
what their parents think as a person who
grew up with parents who differ
politically how did you come into your
views one of the things that happened to
me and I get that question a lot whether
some kind of Epiphany there wasn't it
was gradual but I took a course in
economics you take you how many people
taking the course in economics your life
is different after that you can't look
at minimum wage and go oh you can't you
can't look at zoning laws and say well
these things have prices these things
have costs supply and demand inflation
once you read these kinds of things you
realize how nutty the left is they
really believe that you can jack up the
minimum wage without any adverse
consequences there why are we [ __ ] it
around at $15 make it 50 that way
everybody gets 100 grand if you honestly
believe there are no adverse adverse
effects then Jack it up I'm sorry that's
right sounds good hundred seventy-five
thousand dollars a day plus plus plus
benefits the reason I know is that I
thought about running for Congress real
quick story I had been asked to run for
everything up to an including president
in fact this is an interesting story I
have a friend named Tim Groseclose his
professor wasn't UCLA now he's at George
Mason University Larry wants to come
over to my house this is about a year
before the election got all these graphs
all these papers on his on his desk
he's a he's an economist and a political
science professor
he says Larry run for president you
could win I said whatever you're smoking
I think yes you put it out he said you
could win I said I've never held office
I have no experience he says let me tell
you how he went over the thing he
outlined almost to a tee what Trump did
almost to a tee not saying I would have
done it but I was prevailed to run for
Senate against Barbara Boxer in
California and and because I cannot
stand her politics this time some people
came to me with serious money serious
clout serious people and I said if I get
the nomination I'll run
against her so I go to Washington DC on
my own dime and I meet with all of these
members of the congressional committee
to recruit Senate candidates John Cornyn
and other mothers Laura tell you about
your family
so I told about my family my dad and
stuff I told you guys and he was really
fascinated by it I met four or five
other senators they all seemed to be
fascinated by my story fascinated by I
knew I had it I get back to LA lax phone
rings we're going with Carly Fiorina I
said why three reasons she's a woman I
said I'll give you that number two she
has more money than you do I'll give you
that number three
she has higher name recognition than you
do oh no she doesn't she may have higher
name recognition in the halls of
Washington DC but not in California the
reason I know that is because a friend
of mine put my name on a poll to find
out what my popularity was and at that
juncture I had a 35% known factor in
California at the same period of time
her first opponent named Bruce Hearst
Anson had a 5% name recognition at that
time her second opponent met Fong had a
5% name recognition so my name
recognition is seven times higher than
the her first two opponents and I
haven't even gotten warmed up yet you
guys are wrong anyway they went with her
and I decided not to do it I could have
still run in the primary buddy would had
to raise money to defeat her and then
then run in the prime in the in the
general and I just didn't want to do it
and if they weren't interested in in
being enthusiastic about me then I'm not
interested in being enthusiastic about
you it's the rough tough grind you have
to be on the phone all day raising money
in a state like California to won and
win in California talking about raising
at least 150 million dollars if you're
gonna be serious 150 million and almost
all of it is TV and radio media and if
you don't have that kind of Jack and and
get the backend behind the Republican
Party you have no hope yes sir
yes no my name is Richard I'm a fellow
Brown University alum all right we've
got several of us in the audience and
many more live streaming you we just
wanted to tell you how proud we are of
you
and to ask how you're feeling about
Brown which was once I guess the bastion
of free speech and intellectual honesty
and now perhaps a little over overboard
just a little itical correctness and
just little Jones in with episode thanks
for coming my pleasure and thank you so
much for that look Brown is just like
the rest of the Ivy's they're all like
that if there's a ivy that's more
conservative I don't know which one it
is they're all like that you know we're
talking about racism when I was at Brown
I think it was Hana who was president
I'm sitting there and then what a few
decades later a black woman became
president of brown and we're still
talking about institutional racism
speaking of rich let me just another
quick thing about that Freddie gray died
in the police van in Baltimore it's one
of the one of the deaths that helped to
spawn this so-called black lives matter
movement Baltimore is a city that's
about 45% black City Council was one
hundred percent Democrat majority black
at the time of Freddie Gray's death the
number one in the department with black
number two in the department is black
mayor is black the state attorney who
brought the charges against six officers
of black three of the six officers black
the judge who presided over two of the
cases and pronounced the cops not guilty
black US Attorney of course black and
the president black president US
Attorney mayor top two people in the PD
three of the six officers black State
Attorney black the judge who ruled on
two of the cases black we're talking
about institutional racism when blacks
are running the institution isn't there
something wrong here I gave a talk at
Ohio State University before the
football team even though I went to
Michigan I got a phone call from a text
from coach Urban Meyer and with his
phone number and he wanted me to come to
the school and give a speech because he
said I know how you feel because your
show is Carrie here in Columbus and I
had a speaker last month who was a black
lives matter proponent got everybody all
upset and I want you to give another
point of view
he said I'm not gonna tell you what I
think I don't get into that but I do
want to have your point of view so I
went there on my own dime and I said
according to Washington Post in 2015
955 people were killed by the police
less than four percent were black men
unarmed killed by white cop last year
there were 17 unarmed black men killed
by cop
and by the way unarmed does not mean not
dangerous Michael Brown was unarmed and
he was still charging towards the
officer they found his DNA on the
officer's gun so just because you're not
armed doesn't mean you're not dangerous
but 17 unarmed by contrast 300 people
were injured by lightning last year now
I don't they don't keep tabs as to race
but let's assume that assume that
lightning kind of did it proportionately
which meant seven percent of the country
is black male that means 21 black men
were injured by lightning you are more
likely to be injured by lightning as a
black male than to be an unarmed black
man killed by the cops
it is rare it almost never happens and
it turns out that there are at least two
studies that suggest cops are more
reluctant to pull the trigger against a
black suspect than white suspect
probably because the fear of being
called a racist and be perhaps even
losing your your pensions if you get
convicted of some sort of crime that you
feel you should have been convicted of
so what cops are doing because of the
black lives matter thing they're pulling
back so crime is up in Chicago crime is
up in st. Louis which is right outside
Ferguson the very people that the black
lives matter claim that they care about
are the ones that are more likely to be
hurt by it an increase in crime and
these are urban blacks well done guys
well done thank you again for coming to
speak mr. elder regarding the civil
rights movement what is the best way by
which to convince people that the civil
disobedience of Martin Luther King was
more effective it brings societal change
than the militants potta stations
well I think you just look at what
happened over the last several decades
and see that that king that King clearly
was right let me say something about the
civil rights movement the civil rights
movement jumped the track when people
went from demanding equal rights to
demanding equal results those are two
very different things
and what I found puzzling about Obama I
mentioned that his interview with 60
minutes Obama when he was Senator gave a
speech before a historically black
college on an anniversary of the bloody
Selma March and he said that my
generation which he called the Joshua
generation has to get us the rest of the
way there
MLK's generation he said the Moses
generation took us 90% of the way there
my generation has to do that 10% this is
only the same guy who said racism is in
our DNA if we're 90 percent of the way
there and this is before you became
president didn't your presidency cut
into that remaining 10 percent just a
little bit I mean honestly there's a
sociologist at Harvard named Orlando
Patterson he's a Democrat all
sociologists are Democrat if you can
name ones Republican I'd love to see him
or her he said America is the least
racist majority white country in the
world has more opportunities blacks are
more prosperous healthier better fed
than any other country on the face of
the earth including all the countries of
Africa so honestly come on work hard
stay focused get an education sooner or
later a bad things are gonna happen
someone's gonna say something to you but
come on I was in Euclid Ohio to the
suburb of Cleveland my second or third
year when I was practicing law so I must
have been 28 years old and I had just
done a deposition with a orthopedic
surgeon and my opposing counsel and I
were in front of an officer the doctor's
office is talking and he's my opposing
counsel white car drives by Euclid is
almost all white car drives by
slowly raggedy car four or five teenage
white guys in there
hey n-word
what are you doing in Euclid the sun's
about to go down get out of here and
David David my opposing counsel shocked
he said David they're cowards punks they
wouldn't even stop Here I am at Squire
Sanders and Dempsey making the
equivalent of $150,000 a year and these
guys are driving a raggedy car calling
me an inward and I'm posted lose sleep I
don't think so
I don't think so doesn't work that way
wrong guy this will be our final
question okay thank you thank you
this is a pretty difficult question for
me to ask but you're gonna do it anyway
yeah so I just I just have some sort of
feeling that you and a lot of people in
your family have been in a lot of
situations where you look around the
room and there's just not a lot of
there's just not a lot of you there
there's just not a lot of people that
you see that look a lot like you and I
just want to know how having a lot of
experiences like that like throughout
your life have affected the way you see
yourself as a person and the way you see
other people does it affect you here
sort of in what way I don't know it was
just tough like it's just difficult to
feel like you have I don't know the same
connection with maybe the next person
you see that you know greets you as you
know you might some someone that that
does look like you just because the way
I understand I understand how do you
think Jackie Robinson felt probably a
similar way what'd he do I mean he kept
playing going kept going
III was in pepper pike which is a suburb
of Cleveland once and I was watching
concert when my favorite singers is is
Johnny Mathis I mentioned Cleveland is
about
50 60 % black but I would say that my
girlfriend and I were the only black
people in that building aside from the
people that work there and she mentioned
it to me and I said I certainly hope
that it doesn't bother Johnny who didn't
bother me the door the door was open
$20 to come and see him nobody is
stopping him nobody is stopping black
people from applying here at Hillsdale
nobody is stopping anybody from coming
here if they get accepted you did it
there's no reason why other blacks can't
do it as well
by the way you remember the [ __ ]
comment that Trump made what he said was
that why are we bringing all these
people from s whole countries like Haiti
and like countries in Africa do you know
Obama said something very similar
nobody said Jack there's a get an
article the Atlantic
I think it's may 2016 article about
Obama's foreign policy frustrations and
he was talking about how frustrated he
was he couldn't help to bring peace to
the Middle East and he said this is a
paraphrase that's pretty close if
everybody over there thought the way
Scandinavians did all of this would be
easy
end of quote isn't Norway a Scandinavian
country if everybody in the Middle East
thought the way Scandinavians did all
this would be easy
how is that any different than Trump
saying why are we bringing in people
from s whole countries like Haiti and
like those from Africa both of them were
making a value judgment about the
culture of a particular country in fact
Obama was making a value judgment about
two countries two areas Middle East and
Scandinavia nobody said a word he also
referred to Libya as a blank show and he
wasn't just talking about the fact that
they had a civil war he also talked
about tribal divisions so he too was
making a cultural statement about the
inferiority of a country also in Africa
known as Libya nobody said a word Trump
says something oh my goodness let's
bring out the pitchforks it's Trump
derangement syndrome okay anyway thank
you very much we should